que gilbert collard député européen du
rassemblement national gilbert collard
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france
alors devant le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale jean castex a abordé des
dossiers auxquels vous êtes
particulièrement attentif je pense entre
autres aux délits et incivilités de la
vie quotidienne avec la volonté de
réinventer le juge de proximité la
question aussi d'une loi contre le
séparatisme islamistes à l'école vous
lui apportez votre crédit sur ces
dossiers non non non je pense que on a
été payée en reformant les deux mots je
vais vous donner deux exemples en ce qui
concerne la création de ceux de ce juge
des incivilités
c'est vraiment nous prendre pour des
projets pour des imbéciles
il existe le tribunal de police il
existe le tribunal correctionnel le code
pénal à plus de 1000 articles
il suffirait simplement d'avoir le
courage de faire appliquer la loi
notamment dans ce qu'on appelle les
zones d'un endroit où les quartiers
maintenant perdu de la république
ensuite comment concilier le fait que le
premier ministre veut y mener un combat
légitime contre l'islam radical contre
le séparatisme
contre le communautarisme quand il dit
tout cela
tandis que le ministre de la justice qui
le regarde a déclaré que ç'avait été un
honneur pour lui de défendre
abdelkader meira il ya un moment donné
quand même où la réalité des faits est
plus forte que le gargarisme des mots
donc je ne vois pas comment en présence
de ces de ses contradictions
ce gouvernement pourrait réaliser en 600
jours à l'essai alors que en trois ans
le but n'a été marqué donc c'est
vraiment une fois de plus vendre de la
fausse monnaie de mots aux françaises et
aux français qui s'en rendront donc
c'est dommage
moi franchement
je serais très heureux si un
gouvernement quelconque pouvait ramener
la paix la tranquillité et la sérénité
dans notre pays mais je ne crois pas que
là on a trouvé la solution
malheureusement autres dossiers abordés
la relocalisation de l'industrie et le
gouvernement a promis une baisse massive
20 milliards d'euros des impôts de
production dans le but affiché de re
localiser l industrie et d'asseoir son
indépendance c'est un bon levier selon
vous il faut voir comment d'abord les
régions vont pouvoir se réapprovisionner
en finance ensuite tout ce qui est de
l'ordre de l'économie locale de
l'économie du terroir c'est une très
bonne chose
nous y sommes favorables depuis très
longtemps et rappelez vous à l'époque
quand on le prenait on été caricaturé
avec un béret un béret basque sur la
tête
ddd des pinces à vélo au mollet et une
flûte de pain sous le bras quand c'était
pas un camembert dans la poche bon voilà
maintenant que les gens m'aiment qui
nous critiquaient découvre les vertus de
la région du terroir à une condition
quand même c'est que piliers de la
démocratie régionale notamment en
occitanie on se rend compte que madame
delga qui préside fait ce qu'elle veut
comme elle veut quand elle veut où elle
veut et qu' il n'y a aucune démocratie
des virades délibérative
il faut que vraiment on ait un
rééquilibrage des pouvoirs politiques au
sein des assemblées pour qu'il y ait une
véritable discussion démocratique et non
pas l'autorité gagnante d'une majorité
qui en rapporte et un pouvoir électoral
qui lui permet finalement de faire ce
qu'elle veut ce qui pas du tout
compatible avec une idée de vie
démocratique locale
effectivement nous devons réarmer nos
territoires a insisté le chef du
gouvernement vous le soulignez à
l'assemblée nationale mais notamment
avec le renforcement des effectifs de
fonctionnaires dans les départements
quelle est votre avis sur cette nouvelle
forme finalement de décentralisation on
va d'autre est-ce qu'on n'a pas assez de
fonctionnaires dont il fut un temps on
disait qu'il y en avait trop bon qu'on
déploie des fonctionnaires
dans les territoires c'est une bonne
chose bon mais faudrait-il encore on est
un plan d'études sur l'organisation de
nos administrations sur la
redistribution du travail dans une
administration
on fonctionne d'une manière qui est
irrationnel
on sait d études ont été effectuées là
dessus le travail est mal réparti les
tâches sont mal réparties et avant de
2,2 de renforcer le corps
administratives des régions des
territoires ce qui serait toujours une
bonne chose bien évidemment il serait
quand même pas inutile de se poser la
question du sud de la rationalisation du
travail dans les administrations
pour conclure il nous reste quelques
secondes la crise sanitaire bien
évidemment au coeur du discours et ce
port du masque est obligatoire dès la
semaine prochaine qu'est ce que vous
dites
il était temps écoutez moi je me suis
fait traiter de personnages
apocalyptique il ya quelques jours sur
une autre chaîne que la vôtre parce que
je préconisais le retour immédiat au
masque je pense que l'épidémie hélas est
de retour et que le gouvernement tarde à
dire qu'il faut prendre très vite des
mesures de protection c'est donc une
bonne chose que l'on rétablisse
l'obligation de porter le masque on
aurait dû à mon avis dès le confinement
rendre obligatoire le port du masque là
le gouvernement a fait un peu je joue
pour être agréable avec la santé des
français et c'est aussi une part de
légèreté et d'irresponsabilité qui vient
s'ajouter à la légèreté et à
l'irresponsabilité avec lesquels la la
lutte contre la pandémie a été organisée
merci à vous hilbert que l'art d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes député européen du
rassemblement national